je suis super agitée en fait je vais
revenir sur un bail ouais c'est bien
alors un bail sayos et un tiers sa web
on a vu votre photo à l'écran ah oui la
fameuse et je me pose des questions je
me dis mais qui d'autre fait ça comme
animateur déjà dit c'est quoi la la la
la belle aux relations n'étaient pas là
hier merci ils sont en train de
rechercher en belgique a scoré lyon ils
ont traîné des vrais faux de dire que
dans la scène régis vous êtes vous êtes
vous êtes réveillé ont fait le tour a
donc servi à plusieurs questions si
railway
j'aimerais savoir déjà qu'est ce qui
vous a pris je vais faire ce type de
photo mais alors mais oui je vous ai
déjà dit non non non non j'aimerais que
je disais la vérité quoi c'est quoi or
et de 9,1
mais arrêtez avec ac c'est un copain
n'ont jamais remis de serviette pour une
meuf cédant 5 c dans un groupe de potes
voilà non il ya un mec qui veut parce
que en fait je fais des combats et y'a
un mec mais se battre avec voir à quoi
on organise avec des copains des petits
combats entre nous comme ça tu auras
voilà et donc voilà et donc je suis dit
si tu pas vraiment m'affronter mois et
donc je suis dit je veux montrer un
petit peu la personne voilà c'est vrai
voilà c'est jonathan
voilà c'est tout c'est tout c'est juste
du mal ay croire voilà je vous dis il
faut dire la vérité de temps en temps si
vous avez un 10/10 que maintenant au
tessin j'avais le choix je préfère pas
il ya un petit rhume
ja alors je vous jure il n'y a aucun dos
vraiment à gelos reding a aucun n'ose
bernard montiel et là on aime soit on
peut également pas retenu il faut te dis
qu'il a fait torse nu pour brigitte
macro ont là ici merci donne au fric